hello and welcome to the new world
review i'm grand lime waifu and today it
is the day my goodness it's been quite
the journey hasn't it more than a year
and many many many mispronounced and
forgotten names to get us to the point
where i can say we're going to take a
look at the last existing episodes of
hunter hunter episodes 147 and 148 and
see if absolutely everything or
absolutely anything has been resolved
let's get into it episode 147 and i
really like the cyclical nature of some
of tagashi's decisions if anything i
think i'm less interested in whether
everything is resolved and more
interested in what is resolved because
the way tagashi works we can assume i
will assume by now that takashi is
afraid of endings because if you end
things there's no chance of it coming
back if you resolve someone's story what
need do they have to go out into the
world everything related to gone in this
episode was sort of a cleanup for the
first time the boys are choosing to take
time away from each other it's
interesting that earlier in the arc
kilauea said that things would change
once he saved gone because i don't know
if this is what he meant and i don't
know if this is what he expected to
happen the episode was very much about
apologies how to apologize how to atone
koala friend felt that he needed to
atone for the death of the red-haired
woman who occupied that body before kite
we haven't seen koala boy in so long i
did wonder what his deal was but i don't
know if i ever expected this to be
resolved takashi has this really
interesting way of bringing back
characters i sort of forgot to care
about and use them not to move the story
along but to highlight another aspect of
it and make a point i don't care about
the koala's plight at all because i
don't need to i'd argue i'm not supposed
to what i am supposed to do is consider
kite's response to the story which is
somewhat in opposition to what jing told
gone to do when apologizing the
interesting thing with kait's response
to the koala is that kaise is the one
who decided what atonement the koala
would give the koala apologized or
confessed i suppose and did that for his
own reasons but kite then took it way
over the top by saying that you're going
to live forever and apologize forever in
their own way kite became the avenging
angel atonement is very different to
apology and atonement is very different
to behavior change the koala could
apologize every day could do what kite
says every day of his life then still
come back because the change was not
sold deep kite's suggestion that the
koala must now atone is even more odd to
me given the koala felt he was killing
her to free her from a cycle he doesn't
know exists in a strange sort of way
kite's punishing the koala for mercy
then follows up by denying the koala
that same mercy and i guess the value
system is just very strange to me
especially when we follow it up with
gone and kite's conversation we see such
a powerful difference between the two
gone apologizes and it seems to be only
because kite themself also needs to
atone for something putting gone into a
situation he wasn't ready for and that
allows for that distinct difference in
behavior how kite has become the judge
and jury i'm not sure but i suppose if
you have a lot of people coming to you
to apologize for not doing more you get
that privilege i guess meanwhile i loved
that killer didn't let gon drop his
apology he mocked him soundly for it
first jokes are interesting things
because when we joke there's a kernel of
belief at the center of it a kernel that
we have to accept as part of it for it
to be funny the colonel at the center of
kiehl's joke with gone is that he was
left hurt and gone has to accept and
live with that in order to laugh or move
past it that does indicate they can move
past it and be friends and i really like
that and it's really important because
by the time we get to this penultimate
episode kiawah's finally figured out
what he wants to do both of these kids
have had a very specific goal to their
journeys gone wanted to find his father
while kiwa wanted to figure out what he
wants to do with his time what he wants
to do with his life at many points
throughout the series kilwa has
very specifically been following gone
because he didn't know what else to be
doing with his time now he has alaka and
something to take care of he's found his
purpose or at least until alaka loans
him to gone because that was an amazing
moment alec is setting them up for a
date even alaka sees the situation for
what it is killer can't follow gone like
a puppy anymore because he knows what he
needs and what he wants isn't purely
gone related anymore and that's some
beautiful growth you know and gone well
gone managed to find his dad and this is
what i meant about the cyclical nature
of things episode 1 we were in a tree
with gone here at the end we're in a
tree with him and his dad gone was
always on an adventure to find his dad
but more than that he was on a journey
to understand why his dad enjoyed
hunting having accidentally stumbled
across his dad while lying in a
mummified state did he learn that i'm
hoping that's one of the answered
questions so let's take a look at the
final episode so the final episode of
hunter hunter if there is any more to
this show i don't think it will fit as
well as what we got i mean all the
flashbacks and the climbing and the
wonder of the size of the tree truly did
make for a nice jumping off point as it
were and i really love what jing had to
say to gone about why he left he had a
reason a strong reason not only did he
have a reason but he had learning to
pass on experiences he's had have been
paralleled to gons surprisingly closely
but i don't think gone could have
understood them or truly come to terms
with the meanings of them without jinx
wrapping up of those experiences it
continues that cyclical nature of things
knowing that jing had to learn how to
appreciate the happiness of those around
him there are distinct differences
between jing and gon and i think one of
them is the interaction with the world
jing left because he was curious as did
gone but where one was curious about
what he hadn't seen the other was
curious about what he hadn't seen jing
left because he wanted to know what was
out there gone left because he wanted to
know what jing wanted now that he knows
what jing wants and how his father
relates to the world i imagine he can
understand where he wants to go from
here but really if you look at the
conversation they had gone is now in the
same position keowa was in when he
decided to follow gone kilwa went with
gon because he didn't know what he
wanted gon now gets to spend some time
figuring out what that is the trope of
the real treasure being the friends we
find along the way is a nice way to end
a series based around a character i've
repeatedly questioned as not being able
to empathize with others there's
something magical about the entire
journey existing in order for him to
learn how to empathize in just enough
time for him to meet his dad who seems
to be stacked so full of empathy that
his original goal was superseded in
happiness by the happiness on others
faces i also loved that jinx's game was
a metaverse version of what he knew his
world was a smaller subset of a broader
world i'm entertained by the way that
was represented artistically and there
were so many odd perspectives in that
one image of the world the big world the
extra world outside the world you know
yeah i'm not sure what to believe other
than that is jing's internal
representation of what the world might
look like and i almost understand now
why the hunter exam exists we got there
there are people out there who
understand that the world is bigger and
broader and more dangerous than anyone
could possibly realize but it takes
those four elements to be able to take
them on especially since going into the
world could result in someone or
something following you back if you
return which leads me to wonder whether
the queen ant floated in from outside
the humanish world or if she was tempted
in she suggested at one point that maybe
she had some human in her and if she
came from another world it would make
sense that humans in fact created the
issue they then had to resolve right
because that's that is what humans do
monsters those four aspects really
resonated with me authorization means
there's a group that know about it means
says there's a correct way to do it
qualification and the fact that he
doesn't have it suggest that even jing
has a long way to go to be able to
survive that broader world and a
contract that suggests people might want
it explored jing knows something about
all of them he's worked too hard not to
know anything about any of them but he
doesn't tell gone because that's part of
the game ultimately the sharing of
stories between them shows that gone has
been accepted by his father so jin can
only say that his son found him despite
his best wishes and despite the fact
that he kind of accidentally stumbled
across him you know that doesn't matter
good job as they laughed i did kind of
think of that point and thought i'd be a
really dick move if he went
zoom and disappeared again because being
found is his way of showing appreciation
for another hunter the outro of the
final episode made it though right it
made the entire episode seeing everyone
becoming who they were supposed to
become having those couple of
resolutions you know it was enough i
wish milky moomoo's hawk had shown up
but otherwise i really enjoyed what we
got kurapika and his eye collection was
a clear favorite for me i'm somewhat
surprised and sad we didn't get a final
shot of hiskey but maybe that's to be
expected i'd have liked to know where he
ended up but unsatisfied is probably the
the fact of the matter isn't it really
leorio in what we assume is a consulting
doctor's office or at least rich which
is exactly what he wanted and you know
he deserves it ultimately the only
important character that died in the
entire series being natero i mean other
than uh the the the ants the ant king
and his queen which was a beautiful
thing for us to see just saying but
beyond those two dying the only
important character that died in the
series was the tarot and that was
poignant and pointed and i really love
that someone with such a zest for life
gave his up to make sure the rest of
them could continue to bumble their way
through between the first arc where he
spent his time playing with the boys to
learn their potential to the point where
we saw his gratitude for existence to
his willingness to give himself over to
the world with that gratitude there have
been a lot of really interesting
messages that came from the series the
idea that there's nothing to distinguish
human from monster and that even if we
think we know we really don't the idea
that sometimes the best revenge is
revenge we refuse to take the idea that
there's no point in being the best if
there is no one at the top for you to
play with the idea that all the power in
the world won't win you the game the
idea that the pleasure we see on the
faces of others can be its own reward
and the idea that maybe sometimes the
detours are what make the journey worth
taking this series was one hell of a
detour for me and one that overall i
quite enjoyed so all i can say is enjoy
the little detours to the fullest even
if they're 148 episodes long stay
hydrated enjoy some fresh air and maybe
i'll see you next time